this is jackson a 16 year old golden  eagle  [Music]  we almost lost these beautiful birds but  now they're bouncing back  golden eagles are excellent hunters and  extremely fast  diving at speeds greater than 150 miles  per hour  this makes the golden eagle one of the  fastest animals on earth  when hunting they use their sharp talons  to grab their prey  golden eagles have been known to hunt  animals as large as deer and grey wolves  their feathers are dark brown with  lighter golds around their head and neck  in the 1960s ranchers feared that they  were eating their livestock and over 20  000 were shot  since then through education their  numbers have restabilized and their  biggest threat now is habitat loss  this is the golden eagle  [Music]  you